>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, HERE I AM.
AS NEW YORK CITY BURNED, HE WAS
ABOUT GOVERNOR RANDY CUOMO SAID
ON TUESDAY ON TWITTER.
"THERE ARE THOSE WHO WANT TO
INTENTIONALLY BLUR THE LINES
BETWEEN PEACEFUL, LEGITIMATE
PROTESTERS AND LOOTERS.
THE PRESIDENT IS AMONG THEM.
THEY WANT YOU TO WATCH THE
VIDEOS OF THE LOOTING, NOT THE
VIDEO OF MR. FLOYD BEING
MURDERED.
DON’T FALL FOR IT."
A GOVERNOR WHOSE CITIZENS AND
TAXPAYERS ARE UNDER ATTACK
CLAIMS THE BIGGEST PROBLEM IS
WITNESSING THE ATTACK, THE
MAYHEM, THE ELUDING COME OF THE
ATTACKS ON COPS BECAUSE THAT
BLURS THE LINE BETWEEN PEACEFUL
PROTESTS AND LOOTERS.
I SUPPOSE HE WOULD PREFER YOU
WATCH THIS OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
>> THIS MOVES THE ACTUAL SWAB
THAT WAS BEING USED TO FIT UP
THAT DOUBLE BARREL SHOTGUN YOU
HAVE MOUNTED ON THE FRONT OF
YOUR PRETTY FACE.
>> Greg: I WILL NEVER GET
TIRED OF THAT.
SO WHO IS BLURRING THE LINES
BETWEEN PROTESTERS AND LOOTERS?
IT’S NOT ME, IT’S PEOPLE LIKE
HIM BECAUSE EVERY TIME YOU
MENTION THE RIOTERS THEY ACCUSE
YOU OF SMEARING PROTESTERS.
WE DO UNDERSTAND THE DIFFERENCE.
AS HE?
DO YOU REMEMBER WHEN YOU
CONDEMNED THE ACTIONS OF
JIHADISTS AND SUDDENLY THEY
ACCUSE YOU OF ISLAMOPHOBIA?
WHEN YOU CRITICIZE BEHEADINGS
THAT WAS THE SAME AS CALLING ALL
MUSLIMS EXTREMIST.
THAT IDIOTIC RESPONSE REVEALS
WHO DOES OF THE BLURRING.
BY EXPOSING THE VIOLENT MOB YOU
PROTECT THE FUTURE OF LEGITIMATE
PROTESTS.
NOT DOING IT FOREVER LINKS INTO
DESTRUCTION AND DEATH WHILE
SAYING OR IMPLYING THAT BLACK
GRIEVANCE ONLY MATTERS IF IT’S
EXPRESSED VIOLENTLY, THAT’S
NUTS.
IF THAT’S WHAT YOU’RE SAYING,
ANDY, YOU’RE THE ONE SOWING
DISCORD.
YOU’RE THE ONE WHO LEFT US
HANGING, SACRIFICING CITIZENS TO
THE MOB SO WE DON’T BLUR ANY OF
YOUR PRECIOUS LINES.
LAWRENCE, IN THE A BLOCK I
WASN’T AWARE OF THE VICTIM’S
BROTHER COMING OUT AND BASICALLY
SAYING EXACTLY THE POINT AND THE
THING IS I THINK BOTH SIDES OF
THIS DEBATE AGREE THAT
CONFLATING PROTESTS HANDWRITING
IS WRONG, WE JUST WANT BOTH
SIDES TO IDENTIFY THEM AS
DIFFERENT AND THEN WE’D BE HAPPY
HAPPY.
>> Lawrence: OR JUST GO AND
PICK UP THE BAD GUYS SO WE CAN
HAVE A PEACEFUL PROTEST, GO PICK
THEM UP.
AS I’M WALKING HOME FROM THE
STUDIO I SEE THEM JUST
LOLLYGAGGING IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD
AND I DON’T UNDERSTAND, WHY
DIDN’T THEY PICK THEM UP?
ANTIFA JUST LOOKING IN THE
STREETS.
TODAY IS THE DAY WE ARE
REFLECTING ON GEORGE FLOYD AND
THE MEMORIES HE HAD AND THERE’S
BEEN A LOT OF TALK ABOUT HIS
PAST AND YOU KNOW, GEORGE FLOYD
WAS -- HE HAD A PAST BUT GUESS
WHAT?
IN AMERICA AND AS A BELIEVER
THIS IS A PLACE FOR REDEMPTION
AND HE TURNED HIS LIFE AROUND
AND HE WORKS HARD AND HE DECIDED
THAT HE WAS GOING TO DO
COMMUNITY GROUPS WITH PEOPLE AND
BIBLE STUDIES, THAT’S WHAT WE
WANT TO REMEMBER SO I SAID THAT,
THE PROTESTERS IN THE LOOTERS,
THE PROTESTERS ARE DOING IT THE
RIGHT WAY BUT THE LOOTERS,
YOU’VE GOT TO ULTIMATELY PICK A
SIDE.
GEORGE FLOYD PICKED A SIDE AND
HE DECIDED TO TURN HIS LIFE
AROUND, YOU CAN DO THE SAME,
THERE IS NO REASON TO DESTROY
YOUR ENTIRE COMMUNITY, THERE IS
NO REASON, DOESN’T BRING A
MONARCH, THE FAMILY HAS SAID
THAT DOES NOT BRING HIM HONOR.
LOOK AT HIS PAST VIDEOS, HE
DOESN’T LIKE THAT.
AT THIS POINT YOU’RE DOING IT
FOR YOURSELVES.
>> Greg: YEAH.
JUAN, ONE THING I NOTICED THAT I
FIND FUNNY IS THAT THE BLACK
MEMBERS OF THE PROTEST MOVEMENT
ARE SICKENED BY THE RIOTERS AND
THE AGITATORS BUT IT’S THE WHITE
LIBERALS IN THE ACTIVIST GROUPS
WHO ARE CAREFUL TO VIRTUE SIGNAL
AND NOT ACTUALLY SAY ANYTHING
ABOUT THE RIOTING AND LOOTING,
IT’S THE PROTEST MOVEMENT WHO
UNDERSTAND THE DANGER OF THE
RIOTING MORE THAN ANYBODY ELSE,
LIKE MR. FLOYD’S BROTHER.
>> Juan: LOOK, I DON’T THINK
IT IS -- I THINK YOU OFTEN TALK
ABOUT THE PRISON OF TWO IDEAS SO
LET’S GET OUT OF THE TWO IDEAS
BECAUSE TO ME IT’S NOT A
ZERO-SUM GAME, RIGHT?
TO ME YOU CAN CONDEMN THE
LOOTING AS CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
WHAT YOU CAN ALSO CONDEMN WHAT
HAPPENED IN TERMS OF THAT AWFUL,
TORTUROUS MURDER OF GEORGE FLOYD
SO LOOTING AND RIOTING, YOU SAY,
IT’S JUST BLACK PEOPLE.
I SAY THIS AS SOMEONE WHO
STUDIED THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT OF THE 1960s WHICH
PROVIDED SUCH TREMENDOUS SOCIAL
CHANGE FOR OUR COUNTRY THAT IT
WAS A NONVIOLENT SOCIAL PROTEST
MOVEMENT.
A LOT OF TIMES THE VIOLENCE CAME
FROM THE GOVERNMENT OR FROM
WHITE SUPREMACISTS.
THAT DIDN’T COME FROM THE
PROTESTING.
THEY ACHIEVED REAL, SOLID CHANGE
CHANGE.
I WOULD SAY TO ALL OF THE
COUNTRY AT THIS MOMENT THAT
BUILDING COALITIONS FOR CHANGE,
PERSUADING PEOPLE OF THE
GOODNESS OF YOUR CAUSE IS ABOUT
PEACEFUL PROTESTS, THAT’S WHY
I’M SO PLEASED TO SEE THAT WE
HAVE HAD SO MUCH MORE PEACEFUL
PROTESTS IN THE LAST FEW DAYS.
ONE LAST THING, WHAT YOU’VE SAID
ABOUT THE SOCIETY.
A STRONG REPUBLICAN, SOMEONE WE
ALL KNOW WHO SAID THIS SOCIETY
IS NOT COLOR-BLIND AND PROBABLY
NEVER WILL BE END UNTIL WE ARE
HONEST IN THAT RACE IS IN ANCHOR
AROUND OUR COUNTRY’S NECK, THAT
SHADOW WILL NEVER BE LIFTED.
>> Greg: THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND YOU’RE DEAD WRONG ABOUT WHAT
I SAID, I DIDN’T SAY IT WAS JUST
BLACK PEOPLE, YOU TOOK WHAT I
SAID INCORRECTLY AND THAT WAS
REALLY BAD.
I SAID IT’S A BLACK PEOPLE WHO
ARE UPSET ABOUT THE RIOTING, I
DIDN’T SAY IT WAS JUST BLACK
PEOPLE RIOTING AND I WISH YOU
WOULDN’T HAVE SAID THAT.
>> Juan: I DIDN’T SAY THAT.
>> Greg: YOU SAID --
>> Juan: THAT’S NOT WHAT I
SAID.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, I HEARD IT
IT.
>> Juan: I SAID IT’S NOT JUST
BLACK PEOPLE WHO ARE UPSET AT
THE RIOTING, GREG.
>> Greg: I DIDN’T HEAR IT THAT
WAY.
IF YOU SET IT THAT WAY, I
APOLOGIZE BUT THIS IS A SHOW IN
WHICH PEOPLE CAN GET THINGS
RIGHT MOST OF THE TIME AND
SOMETIMES GET THINGS WRONG WHICH
IS RARE, JUAN, IT IS RARE THAT I
GET THINGS WRONG.
>> Dana: VERY RARE.
>> Juan: VERY RARE, VERY RARE.
>> Greg: DANA?
JUAN BRINGS UP THE CONDI RICE
QUOTE WHICH I FIND INTERESTING
BECAUSE NO ONE IS DENYING THAT
RACISTS EXIST.
I AM DENYING THAT IT’S A RACIST
SOCIETY, THAT CAN EXIST
SIMULTANEOUSLY.
>> Dana: YEAH AND I THINK ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT CONDI RICE
ALSO HAS SET IN THE PAST THAT
ALWAYS STUCK WITH ME IS THAT
AMERICA WAS BORN WITH A BIRTH
DEFECT AND WE’VE BEEN DEALING
WITH THAT BIRTH DEFECT FOR A
LONG TIME AND OBVIOUSLY OUR
NATION FOUGHT A WAR OVER IT.
I THINK WHAT YOU’RE SAYING IS
ALSO THERE IS OPPORTUNITY HERE
FOR ALL OF US TO BELIEVE IN THE
AMERICAN IDEAL BECAUSE AMERICA
IS NOT A COUNTRY WHERE WE ARE
JUST SHARING BLOODLINES.
WE CAME TOGETHER BECAUSE OF
IDEAS AND THAT’S WHAT HOLDS US
TOGETHER, THAT’S THE FABRIC,
THAT’S THE GLUE.
YOU CAN’T LET ANYBODY TAKE THAT
AWAY FROM US AS A NATION OF SOUL
AND FOREIGN NATIONS BILL BARR
SAID TODAY, FOREIGN NATIONS HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO USE THIS TO
CREATE MORE TENSION WITHIN OUR
COUNTRY, IGNORE THEM, DO NOT
WORRY ABOUT WHAT OTHER NATIONS
ARE THINKING AND WHEN IT COMES
TO ANTIFA FOR EXAMPLE, HENRY
ROGERS CALLED EVERY SINGLE
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR’S OFFICE
TODAY ASKING FOR SOME SORT OF
CONDEMNATION, GOT NONE, THERE IS
NONE.
SO MAYBE THEY AREN’T BLURRING
THE LINES.
MAYBE DONNA CLEAR LINE.
>> Greg: YEAH.
KATIE, WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> Katie: GREG, I WANT TO GET
BACK TO YOUR POINT ABOUT
BLURRING THE LINES BETWEEN THE
PROTESTERS AND THE RIOTERS AND A
LOT OF IT HAS TO DO WITH THE
DEMOCRATS IN CHARGE NOT WANTING
TO TAKE HER SPOTS ABILITY FOR
WHAT HAS GONE ON, WHETHER IT’S
BILL de BLASIO,
GOVERNOR CUOMO, THE MAYOR OF
D.C. AND ALSO WHEN YOU BLUR
THOSE TWO LINES YOU DO A
DISTURBANCE TO THE VERY PEOPLE
YOU SAY AND CLAIM YOU ARE
STANDING UP FOR AND PROTECTING
SO FOR EXAMPLE THE BLACK WOMAN
IN THE BRONX WHO LOST HER STORE
TO LOOTERS WHO SAID I AM BLACK,
AND NOW MY STORE WHICH I
PARTIALLY OWN AND WORK FOR HAS
BEEN DESTROYED AND THE JOBS OF
THE PEOPLE WHO WORK HERE HAVE
BEEN DESTROYED.
WHAT ABOUT THE BLACK OFFICERS
WHO HAVE BEEN KILLED AS A RESULT
OF THESE RIOTS?
SO THERE NEEDS TO BE A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THE TWO FOR
THE SAKE OF ACCOUNTABILITY AND
PREVENTING THE VERY COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE IMPACTED THE MOST BY
THIS FROM BEING HURT FURTHER BY
A GROUP THAT IT HAS COMPLETELY
HIJACKED THE NARRATIVE AND THE
CAUSE ON THIS AND IF YOU WANT
PEOPLE TO TAKE THIS SERIOUSLY,
YOU WANT PEOPLE TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH UNITY, YOU HAVE TO MAKE THE
DISTINCTIONS OF PEOPLE KNOW THAT
THE TWO GROUPS ARE NOT MIXED OR
THEY ARE GOING TO SEE THEM AS
ONE AND ACCORDING TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND THAT’S NOT
WHAT’S HAPPENING HERE.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT.
BEFORE WE COME BACK I’M GOING TO
LOOK AT THE TAPE OF ME AND WANT
AND IF HE IS WRONG I AM TPING IS
A HOUSE.
>> Dana: DO NOT WASTE TP!